pourquoi nos doigs fripent dans l'eau on
ne sait vraiment pas ça ne le fait pas
chez les autres animaux même chez les
chimpanzés ça serait donc exclusif à
l'homme au bout de 10 minutes
d'immersion vous voyez les promist on a
imaginé que c'était une réaction
biochimique osmotique que l'eau
s'infiltre dans la peau et full boxon
mais non en fait c'est notre système
nerveux qui décide de contracter nos
vaisseaux sanguins ils perd en volume
donc la peau sera Bougrie si on coupe
les petits nerfs des doigts il ne fripe
plus si cette réaction existe c'est donc
pour une raison un avantage évolutif la
capacité à mieux s'agrippper au bord
pour éviter la noyade ou mieux capturer
de la nourriture sous l'eau on l'a testé
en laboratoire et ça marche mais c'est
pas non plus extraordinaire si les
singes n'ont pas développé cette
capacité ça serait parce qu'ils évitent
l'eau à l'exception du macaque japonais
qui aurait un phénomène similaire on a
aussi découvert que le fripement des
doigts était le signal de certaines
maladies selon leur vitesse d'apparition
ou leur agencement on pourrait détecter
un diabète de type 2 ou une maladie de
Parkinson mais attention les
scientifiques ne sont pas sûrs à 100 %
de